marc garneau mis les affaires étrangères
monsieur garneau bonsoir
alors où on a le bilan canadien 3700
personnes ont pu gagner le canada ou un
pays tiers en tout cas sont en sécurité
avez-vous l'autre chiffre qui est plus
difficile c'est à dire ce qu'on a
laissée derrière
on n'a pas de chiffres exacts parce que
il faut que un citoyen qui vend en
afghanistan soit enregistré et si c'est
pas quelque chose qui touche des poires
alors on n'a pas de chiffres exacts et
également il ya des canadiens ou des
citoyens tarnac qui aurait pu aller dans
un pays limitrophe et d'autres canadiens
qui auraient pu embarquer sur des vols
des alliés alors on n'a pas les chiffres
exacts pour ses clients c'est sûr et
puis le plus grand chef le 20 mai à
requins vulnérables comme le ramener au
pays ça c'est un travail de plus longue
haleine qui va se faire dans le courant
de la prochaine année ce garneau vous
avez comme moi attendu depuis et deux
chemins de vous lisez dans les journaux
voyelles intelligente des témoignages de
gens qui disent bon peut-être dans les
derniers dix jours on pouvait pas faire
plus parce qu'ils avaient un caroni tout
le monde était confronté aux mêmes ko
tous les pays mais depuis le mois de
février dernier quand monsieur bail de
l'audio ou par pourquoi l'opération de
rapatriement de tous ses avions qui nous
ont aidés n'a pas été faite plus
rapidement
c'est parce que nous avons été tous
surpris par la rapidité avec laquelle le
taliban s'est emparée du pays et la très
très faible résistance de la part de
l'armée afghane nationale alors tout le
monde a été pris au dépourvu et les
choses se sont fait beaucoup plus
rapidement que eu donc vous ne vous ne
reconnaissez pas a posteriori qu'on
aurait pu aller plus vite depuis cessé
mois pour rapatrier ces gens qui
potentiellement est en danger là c'est
toujours facile de regarder par en
arrière et de dire qu'on aurait pu dû
commencer plus rapidement mais je peux
vous dire qu'on avait planifié la sortie
sauf que
les événements se sont vu se bousculer
très très rapidement et vous voilà on
est dans la situation qui existe en ce
moment mais je veux réitérer que le
canada s'engage fermement à sortir un
tout ce qu'ils sont des soyez canadiens
et des résidents permanents et désert
vulnérables tels que on l'a promis et au
met en place toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour accomplir cette tâche
combien il y avait de personnel canadien
depuis deux semaines à kaboul
il y avait environ soixante dix
militaires et j'écoutais l'entrevue
steuer deux minutes six militaires ces
forces spéciales sont sortis du de
l'enceinte de l'aéroport pour aller
retrouver des des candidats canadiens
éligibles pour des vols canadiens à il y
avait également quelques employés de mon
ministère est aussi de ministère de
l'immigration tout seul pour s'occuper
de ces gens là une fois rendu dans
l'aéroport les mettre sur les avions on
a fermé l'ambassade comme plusieurs
autres pays monsieur garneau mais nous
contrairement aux britanniques et aux
français et d'autre on n'a pas laissé
sur place un patron l'aéroport de kaboul
dans une ambassade d'urgence on est
revenu au pays est-ce que ça s'arrête
pas aider sur place d'avoir un capitaine
pour coordonner entre l'immigration et
les militaires par exemple
on a rapidement ramené des militaires et
des employés du gouvernement oui ce
moment il y avait personne s'était basé
sur le jugement de l'ambassadeur que je
respecte celui qui responsable l'avis de
tout le monde des employés et des
militaires à ce moment là et qui avait
jugé que c'était important de quitter
pour des raisons de sécurité j'ai
l'obligation morale de prendre en
considération et c'est ce qu'on a fait
mais on a ramené des gens pour faire
tout ce qu'on devait faire pour avoir le
maximum de vols et puis comme vous le
savez on a réussi à en sortir pour 1700
se garent noah en terminant bon pour
ceux qui pour les canadiens et pour les
amis des canadiens les afghans qui sont
encore là il y aura les voitures c'est
ce que ya un plan pour tenter soit par
l'ouzbékistan par le pakistan de faire
sortir ces gens là ces gens le
reconnaissent
le mieux les risques qui sont qui doit
prendre en considération dans les
différentes options de sortie par voie
terrestre moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que nous ambassades ou consulats
seront prêts à les accueillir s'ils
peuvent se rencontrent dans ces pays
anciennes
l'autre option qui est important de
reconnaître c'est que probablement
l'aéroport va rouvrir dans les jours à
venir comme une 1ère au port normal
c'est quelque chose sur lequel
travaillent plusieurs pays avec le
taliban pour les lilas recommandé
d'ouvrir
l'aéroport et ce sera aussi une boîte
sortie par vols commerciaux et
éventuellement est-ce qu'on négocie où
on discute avec les talibans
actuellement
nous avons eu des communications avec le
taliban par par des intermédiaires au
qatar et c'est parce que c'est parfois
nécessaire de passer sur un message ça
n'a rien à faire avec la reconnaissance
des talibans c'est une question de
l'importance d'avoir des canaux de
communication et jusqu ici comment vous
pourriez qualifier la collaboration
entre les taliban et un pays comme le
canada
c'est trop tôt pour le dire
peut être est ce qu'ils sont même pas
vraiment un complètement organisés ils
ont énormément de travail devant eux
pour s'organiser mais c'est sûr que nous
le canada est aussi le g7 et d'autres
groupes multilatéraux on a certainement
des choses à leur dire parce que s'ils
veulent continuer de celui-ci nous nous
voulons continuer d'aider ce pays ont
annoncé aujourd'hui 50 millions en aide
humanitaire il va falloir aussi que le
taliban puisse se faire certaines
conditions si par exemple on parlait de
l'aide au développement
certaines de ces conditions là c'est de
ne pas en cours g ou de permettre
l'incubation de groupes terroristes tels
qu'on en a vu aujourd'hui avec un saut
ce qu'est ce c'est un problème
extrêmement sérieux et deuxièmement de
plus importante c'est un plus grand
respect pour les droits humains
particulièrement les femmes et les faits
ce sont les et d'aider condition
sinequanone que nous allons mettre
devant le taliban
et autres
essais dans les jours à venir sa marque
à renommer les affaires étrangères mais
ça nous avoir parlé on va se reparlent
évidemment de tout ça merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici r d